the
hangout on air is live
i think
we will see welcome
those of you who are there i see zero
viewers
just wait
i guess
one viewer all right
hello there
nine viewers all right we're in business
so here i am
it's uh our second
of these uh language workouts which is
an experiment
and it's done in conjunction with our
90-day challenge
and i will be continuing our week my
twice weekly 90-day challenge videos
i'll be doing one after this session
but
uh and also
so a couple of things here first of all
some of the comments
uh
some suggesting that maybe we could make
these more interactive i'm very open to
the idea of making them more interactive
i don't know how to make them more
interactive if we have 50 60 100 people
it's very difficult for me to answer
everybody's question um if there is some
technology out there where i could ask
questions and people vote on different
subjects and somehow the statistic shows
up as to what people are thinking and so
forth that would be fine
if anyone can suggest such a thing i'd
be very open to it
so obviously we'd like to make it more
interactive you're free to ask questions
and i do get to see the questions and
i'll try to answer them as we go forward
now today it's going to be arabic as you
know my 90-day challenge is farsi and
arabic i'm going to do
basically mondays and wednesdays are
arabic and fridays are farsi but you may
be studying any language
and today i want to talk about something
that relates to a video that i did a
while ago about you know short term
objectives or strategies in language
learning and longer term so
i'm going to show you how i use link and
and then i'm going to try not to make it
too loud so that people who are studying
on their own can do what they want but
obviously you know i have an arabic
discussion at 11 i may even record a bit
of it just to show you and
so i find that the mini stories which
i've listened to many many times help
prepare me for my discussion so that's a
short term objective
but i know
that if i don't get into the more
difficult texts
like political texts
then i won't increase my vocabulary so
on the one hand it's good to go over
especially the many stories which have
so much sort of uh of the most frequent
vocabulary
and it's always i would say humbling to
go back to some story that you've
listened to 30 40 times
and where you all those words you think
you know and you go back there and you
find you don't know them again i mean we
mustn't underestimate our ability to
forget things that we have learned
and there's nothing wrong with that
because when you relearn it
it comes back stronger but the amount of
exposure and speaking and involvement
and immersion in the language that we
need in order to have things really
become natural to us it takes a lot
but again the many stories have the
advantage that you're going over the
basic structures of the language so
often that they just become natural and
you don't have to think of the rules
because you're training yourself to
think of something as natural so
with that and without further ado i am
going to share my screen
and show you in specific sense it turns
what i'm what i'm talking about so
let us go here start screen share
present everyone
i am assuming that you can see my screen
so
so if i look at my lessons in arabic
so i have
uh
for whatever i started out uploading
franz van cat had someone do the uh
transcripts for me then we did a better
version of it so i have two i sometimes
get confused as to which is which
and you'll see that uh
here 32 of the words are blue or unknown
are new to me so here is where i can go
in
and and really start to increase my
vocabulary start to expose myself to
more words and of course my goal is to
get there because when i can download
podcasts from france or from al jazeera
and and actually understand it then i'll
be listening to things that are
interesting and i'll no longer be
deliberately learning the language i'll
be learning the language through things
that are of interest to me however i'm
not there yet if i listen i can work my
way through something which i'm going to
do on wednesday by the way is work my
way through
uh you know creating a lot of new links
uh but i'm not going to do that today
today i'm going to show you how i i mine
how you can use linking as a way to
become more and more familiar with the
basic structures and the basic
vocabulary of the language so leaving
these aside then but again i just want
to point out that i am guided
by these little numbers so there's here
for example
there are 2 300 words that i have
previously saved
links
that i'm in the process of learning but
there's another 1640 words that are
completely new to me
whereas if i go into my link mini
stories which is where i'm going to go
there's not that many new words
and there's a bunch of words 400
some yellow words that probably i'm
getting close to where i
i can use them so let's open this up and
see what we have here
now
what i often do is i go through these i
mean i have i have listened to these as
you'll see
you know
62 times i'd listen to this story all
right
so i'm not going to go there
but i tend to look for the ones where
there are more yellow words in other
words that i haven't
yet
um
learn
and in particular because i was just
doing uh you know cleaning up
first of all i made breakfast and i
cleaned up after breakfast and i was
listening to the more difficult stories
stories that i've listened to less often
so i'm gonna go
pick one here at random here we'll go to
number 59
uh and let's just open that up
and it says there's only seven new words
but
i'm going to show you how you can
you know
go back and review stuff
okay so if i open this up i have
listened to this 22 times i was just
listening to it i've listened to it 22
times it says so right here 22 times
read it it says once because i'm too
lazy to add but actually
i have listened i have read it many
times
the listing is automatic it comes from
the playlist
it says here added to playlist
uh
but i i don't really keep track of how
often i've read it i should but i don't
now
so
if i first thing i can do and i
sometimes do this when i'm reviewing
something that i'm fairly familiar with
i will just go through
reviewing the links
so that's one thing i could do sometimes
i will just go through reviewing the
links
and i won't reread it but normally i'll
review the links then i'll go through
read it again
sometimes with the audio on audio is
here and sometimes without the audio
but the other thing that i think is very
useful
is because
a lot of these um lessons contain some
very good basic structures in the
language so
fatima fatima adata
so she is used to doing something
she used to do something so you know i
might say this is something that i want
to review again
so
used to
allah
so
what i'm doing is i'm creating phrases
that i'm going to review again see i'm
adding them to my review number here i'm
not eight
links that i need to review so what i
would do is i would go through and
create a bunch of phrases
now
uh
so
that
so for whatever reason i decided i knew
that phrase
but if i go there
i should point out that i normally do
this work on my ipad
and so i'm not as familiar with how it
all works on the uh but if if it's still
showing in white
because it's
shown as known but i want to review it
again
then i have to change the numbers so
people often ask you know
if uh if you uh for whatever reason
something's moved to known what do you
do well it's not a problem i can move it
back to unknown
uh
so
el cutto
um
[Music]
so i am going through and picking up
phrases
that i'm going to review
again when i go my through my links
so let's just pick a couple more here
walmart
uh
so again
foreign
there's some weird stuff happening i
must say i do it on the ipad i don't
have any of these issues i'm not sure
why
okay
so and you can go to the next
so uh
i'll just let that ring
uh so the point is once you've done that
so
um
now
remember you can set your review
settings
and um
make sure you set them you know i first
of all i like to see everything on the
front of the of the flash card because i
don't like to work too hard
uh so i just like to see it in front of
me i'm not going to do the closed test
i'm going to do multiple choice which is
the easiest and i do going to do the
dictation all right
so close
so then we go into reviewing these
no
i don't know
unfortunate i must say i haven't been on
the uh the browser version but i'm
seeing that there are some things that
don't work properly on the browser
version the ipad version works fine
uh let's go here see what happens
i wonder what's why that is
uh
i don't know if other people have a
similar
problem
at the moment submit
uh
next
i don't know what's happening here
um yeah i apologize because i don't do
this here i'm either because i'm clumsy
or doing it wrong or there seem to be
things that don't work properly on the
browser
that work very well on the ipad
um
[Music]
what can i say uh
all right i'm going to change
tracks here
let's go
and so what i was going to show you is
that you have to be flexible in your use
of your links that
you can
uh
you know
go through clear out all the words think
you kind of know them go back and find
that you don't know them go back and say
more phrases then review the phrases
and um
actually one thing i was going to show
you but i won't
is that with phrases especially with
phrases you can use the dictation
function
and so you're forced to type out in the
language you're learning
uh the phrases that you hear so uh
you know and then you you also of course
the reverse uh
flash card so the sort of variety of
activities in those flash cards are very
helpful for trying to nail things down
nailing things down which is of course
an illusion because you never nail
things down
um
it's um
you know
the short term type of activity but the
longer term type of activity is when you
go after difficult texts
so
if we go through here this for example
obviously has 26 percent
unknown words so this is going to be
difficult for me
so i'm going to for the next little
while quietly go through this acquiring
new words
or at least starting the process by
saying
and you can um
or
or not as you wish
i don't know why we're getting this echo
alfaro
gonna turn off the sound it's annoying
now i'm using the arrow keys
but uh you can also do it you know if
you just want to go after the blue words
you can use your cursor
but i like to go through the yellow
words as well
and i'm not worried too much about
understanding the whole text i want to
go through and clean up all the blue
words
kind of quickly review the yellow word
and then i'm going to go back in and
read it
and this one is not a word
so i'm just going to give it the
ignore treatment
ignore word
bingo
now one thing is that some of these
words may be not an accurate or a useful
translation
and i'll discover that when i reread it
the second time
and then i will go and consult a
dictionary if i don't like what you know
whatever the hint is here
so
there's nothing permanent about a hint
and if it's a totally inappropriate hint
i'll remove it and i'll put something in
more useful that i got from a dictionary
but i i personally like to go through
and kind of remove all the blue words
review the yellow words
before i get in there and really start
reading it and then after having read it
once or twice i'll try and listen to it
still won't understand it
go back and read it again
but i am adding uh potential you know
words that i can potentially learn to my
database of yellow links
uh and i'll be going back in there many
times to review them in different ways
but again this is plowing forward into
difficult material trying to set myself
up to where i can actually listen to
these and enjoy them while i'm on my
bicycle or whatever
and i know that i've got a long way to
go this is the old hockey upside down
hockey stick
situation where uh
i'm on the long shaft of the hockey
stick it's a long road to get to where i
can understand these things
whereas with the mini stories it's that
steep initial period that steep blade
where we're trying to get a sense of the
language how the language works key
phrases key verbs
and of course if we're preparing to
speak if we need to speak then we put
more time into that process which slows
us down in terms of our acquiring more
vocabulary in the long run we need to do
both and so depending on our needs then
we focus on one or the other
hmm
now some of these words as i look at
them you know
i know them really
uh
you know
koa is strength and high her
taha i would but i i've turned off the
text of speech which i use often to help
me with the pronunciation of the words
in arabic i've turned it off because
we're getting that echo but when i go
back in there
i will
look at these individually again
more carefully
and again you know it says
goal is new but the heart is an ending
which means her and i'm familiar with
that so these words i'm starting to gain
some familiar familiarity with them they
have components that i'm starting to get
familiar with when i go back in as i say
i'm going to work these words harder
so that eventually there'll be fewer
yellow words on the page and more white
words
so this isn't um very interesting
but
just to give you a sense of what i do uh
you can be doing the same in your uh in
your own studies
uh
you know
i i recommend that you spend time
on both that you spend time on uh
on
the steep uh hockey blade the early
portion uh really
learning forgetting learning forgetting
rewording reviewing the verbs and and
the most common verbs the phrases
so that the grammar starts to become
natural to you
when i listen to many stories 30 40
times i always notice phrases and
structures that i kind of had learned
before but learned them theoretically
and and eventually they just start to
seem natural and the meaning just comes
naturally without me having to think
uh whereas here it's much harder going
going through learning new words
uh the second time i go through this
i'll be making sense of it and even if i
make sense of it when i listen to it i
won't really understand it that well but
that's just the process that you have to
go through so i don't know if there are
any questions maybe we could uh you know
if there are any questions i could
answer them now
uh
if not i will continue with this again
questions or even suggestions
in terms of how
you find these
workouts and how we can make them more
useful
also on wednesday i'm going to do this
using my ipad i will connect the ipad
to the computer screen
and that'll be i'm more comfortable
doing it that way so
but i know a lot of you do it on the
browser
so um but there seems to be some issues
with the arabic on the browser i hadn't
encountered those before so
anyway i guess there are no questions so
then i will then
uh
go back to my
okay
so
boy solid blue here again you should be
familiar if you are using the browser
you should be familiar with your
arrow keys
and
in fact
let's go there
the reader settings so
auto link creation review links when
paging you don't have to do that
we have auto grammar tagging now
so that it'll tag it it doesn't work for
all languages but it works for the
more popular languages
at link
so that um
it'll tell you if it's a verb it'll give
you a tag and you can then tag it as a
verb or a noun and that is going to
connect to a grammar source
so that you can review the verbs or the
nouns or the adjectives in that language
um
no i'm not sure i don't know link
creation i'm not sure what this does but
let's close that
so
injured
all right
i guess what it means that
oh yeah it doesn't automatically create
it i like to go with um
auto link creation what i was looking
for was how to go from blue word to blue
word
obviously when i do this on my ipad i
just use my finger
or my stylus but here i'm using the
arrow keys and in the case of
languages that go from right to left
uh it's a little counter-intuitive
you're going to the right but actually
going to the left
if you understand what i mean so i hit
this key
and it takes me to the next word and i'm
using the left arrow key the right arrow
key to go to the left in the case of
arabic
so this is something that you could be
doing you know i like to go through
remove as i say remove the blue words
get uh get it all yellow so that i can
go through it once again and then look
at the hints that i've got saved for the
yellow
uh
at some you'll notice that there aren't
many phrases here
because i'm still trying to make sense
of the text
once i get to the point where i want to
go and mine it for phrases that i can
use then i'll go through it you know yet
another time so i guess the gist of what
i wanted to say today was
that you can use your linking in many
ways some people think that it's just oh
you know you're going to save the word
and eventually you can learn the word
and what happens if i moved it to known
and now i don't know it again none of
that matters
you can always re-link a word
and eventually i think it's very useful
to go back in and just link a bunch of
phrases and then working with your flash
cards review those phrases
in the different uh
you know in the different uh
types of activities that we have again
if we go to the review settings
you know you can set what you want to do
you can do flash cards and within that
you can set
you know what you want to have show up
on those flash cards phrase translation
no reverse trash cards
uh so there's a lot of of uh
you know flexibility
you can also look at however many cards
per session that you want so you know
maybe i'll take it up to 30.
and
but i find that the closed tests are
very good but in arabic uh
it's sometimes the sentences are quite
long and the
font becomes quite small and i find it
difficult
uh so close that sophie then had a look
at that now obviously i have a ton
of uh
another thing one shouldn't look at here
is
if you don't like
like
if if you don't like
the um
dictionary definition that's sitting
there
you can always check because that might
have come from google translate which
isn't always
so this seems to be quite different from
the google translate translation
so that now i will have to go in and
you
know think it said something like that i
tend to trust
uh
i tend to trust the uh
context reversal dictionary
what did they say again
budget for it we'll see when i go
through the text
myself
then i'll see which one of these makes
the most sense
um
now we're running close to our deadline
but
oh and will so you know the hint is what
so it's n maybe we'll see what happens
wrong companions all right
anyway
i just wanted to give you i mean it's a
little difficult for me to pretend that
i'm doing this with everybody watching
but
i'm going to stop this now
stop the screen sharing
all right so
a little bit of a shomazol this morning
because uh
i had some difficulty navigating the
browser version i as i say always do it
on my ipad
but the point i wanted to make is that i
find
two things really number one that i
think there are two types
of
two types of um sort of stages if you
want there's the
the steep climb when we're trying to get
a hang of the language
and then there's that long period of
trying to gain more words so you need to
get that initial traction to get a sense
of how the language works those are the
many stories the easier content that you
have to go over many many times where
you can go in and re-link phrases
re-link words and where you're forever
surprised at how much you've forgotten
of stuff that you actually thought you
knew
and so but you're gaining more and more
traction then the second phase is
acquiring more and more words so that
eventually you can be listening to
interesting stuff that's a long road and
that's where you're going at material
that has a high percentage of blue words
but in both cases you should have a
flexible approach to using your links
you can go in and say i know this go
back in and say i don't know it
create phrases and so forth and so on so
let me now have a look at the questions
that i might have very quickly
so just a second how would you classify
your polish mr steve my polish is what i
would call potential in other words i
can understand a lot of what i hear i
can understand a lot of what i read i
have a large vocabulary i have even
worked on
those things that are different in
polish than in say russian ukrainian
czech
i would have difficulty right now
speaking but if i were to spend
i would say a few hours with my mini
stories i would be doing fine and i
would have enough
traction comprehension that i could get
into a conversation and then if i were
in a polish environment uh my police
would come along just fine
so i i like to classify some of my
languages as potential so i'm kind of b1
to b2 potential with a ver with a large
vocabulary
mr steve use any notebook or justify
computer stuff like that
uh
i don't know what is meant by notebook
i don't write things down if that's
what's meant
i simply
uh
use link
but i also have some textbooks because i
sometimes find it pleasant i think
variety is good so you know on my ipad
read a book this kind of thing
uh how many hours do you study a day
well i have to admit that i'm stepping
it up now because we have this 90-day
challenge so i think i'm probably
depending on the day i might listen for
an hour or so and then probably spend
another hour or so
linking reviewing that kind of thing
what is your advice someone learning
russian from an english perspective
um
okay uh
obviously
you know whether it's an english
perspective or a french or a spanish
perspective the first thing is you're
dealing with
the complexity of slavic languages the
case endings the
verbs of motion the aspects of verbs
things of this nature
uh
i think
my approach to russian was
that that the rules there are so many
rules that it's difficult to remember
the rules
and therefore i would recommend doing
what i did which is exposing yourself to
the language occasionally referring to
the rules just to satisfy your curiosity
but don't expect to remember the rules
don't be don't expect to be able to
apply them don't ignore them
but just
expose yourself to as much of the
language as you can bear
link is a good way to do that
and then yes consult grammar as as as
appropriate and that's why in our new
system where we're gonna you can tag
words for verb noun adjective and then
that is gonna take you to a grammar
which will give you a quick summary of
maybe the declension tables you look at
it has a bit of an impact and you go
back to your text
and over time
you should be starting to feel
that some of these grammar issues become
natural to you and don't underestimate
your ability to forget things that you
think you have learned
uh
what was the hardest language for you
i get asked that a lot i have no idea
um
they're all hard in their own way arabic
is proving hard i mean easy are
for example any language that's part of
the same system so if you're uh you know
romanian was easy because i had
italian and and some slavic because
there's 20 25 slavic words in romanian
so romania was easy
um i honestly feel that language all
languages are easier now for me than
they were before and i attribute that to
the fact that link works better than
before and our mini stories i am strong
a total believer in the many stories
in that early stage to get some traction
in the language
i mean i'm speaking i'm going to be
speaking in arabic in half an hour i
have 7000 words in arabic i was speaking
in farsi the other day i have 1500 words
in farsi
with czech it took me eight months and i
didn't feel confident even trying to
speak until i had
a much larger vocabulary so
uh
doing
okay what is the hardest lame hair would
you still recommend doing flash cards if
that person doesn't like doing them no
i i sometimes don't do the flash cards
sometimes do them i think the important
thing is to vary what you do do things
that you enjoy doing you're going to
come across the words in the text anyway
if you want to do some flashcard review
which i like to do from time to time in
conjunction with the lesson do it if you
don't feel like doing it don't it
depends on your level and the language
your inclination i don't see it as a
necessity at all
how did you master german grammar i
didn't master german grammar
uh
however
once i stopped trying to memorize the
declension tables my german improved a
lot because i was no longer sort of
inhibited and trying to think is it this
or that form and if you expose yourself
to enough of the language some of these
things start to come out naturally and
in time your accuracy improves and every
so often you refer to the table
and it has some impact it's all part of
that learning process but
it's not
mastery mastery is not the word that i
would use you gradually get better
rushing with max steve do you still
practice all the language you learned on
a regular basis basis no
no i wish i could but there is no way i
mean if your goal is to become perfect
in if i want to become perfect in
russian i would spend all my time on
russian but
that's i'm not that interested in
becoming perfect in russia i don't live
in russia i don't i'm not a simultaneous
interpreter
i'm interested in the the fact that i
have been able to to gain some exposure
to russian culture russian movies
russian books
uh
i can follow people on you know youtube
in russian and now i want to be able to
do that in arabic and farsi as well so
with all of mistakes and problems and
stuff if i can access another language
and culture that just adds so much to my
sort of world perspective i'm not that
interested in
in becoming perfect and certainly i'm
not in a position to practice all these
languages all the time
okay
that's it thank you
oh we're up to them ever since i stopped
uh
going through the link i got more
viewers
anyway
that's it no more questions all right i
hope that was helpful and i look forward
to your comments
bye for now